all right I have something extra special
for you today our friend and
correspondent Luke Beasley was in
Latrobe Pennsylvania for the Trump rally
he interviewed a dozen people and we are
going to look at it right now now a few
things that I want to say here and this
I'm not joking about this
when we we're not even playing
everything for you there's some stuff
Luke sent me that seemed so obviously in
the wrong category and I'll tell you the
categories in a second that it just felt
like I just shouldn't even use it okay
but as a general thing
by definition
if you survey the Maga movement they
have delusional incoherent beliefs that
in any other context we would say that's
mental illness and so you go and you
interview people and they all kind of
seem mentally ill
and it really raises a question for
people who are wanting to say let's hear
from this movement there's tens of
millions of these people we want to talk
to them and then you talk to them and
you go can I even air this because they
see mentally ill am I is am I is am I
doing something wrong by showing that
this is what they say there's obviously
cult beliefs in people that are just
sucked into a cult and then there's
ignorance and there's mental illness and
it's a Venn diagram I don't know exactly
where each of these people are but it's
something we really think about and I
cut out some stuff
so let's just start Luke first talking
to a couple of women one of them says
Trump is currently the president The
Other Woman in the middle kind of
doesn't seem to buy it and Luke does a
really good job here let's let's start
and by the way it was really windy so at
certain points there's just like wind
noise Luke did the best he could
even his president really that's the
Tucker Carlson psychotic laugh
so she says Trump's the current
president he will be back any day under
military now look at the look on the
other woman's face she's starting to say
I may be nuts but I'm not as nuts as
this lady
whoa okay but this is the thing that
thing with that filter out
is attacking Biden's performance as
president
but he's the real president yeah yeah
Luke why is that so hard for you to
understand she is so he's to blame for
inflation
no
no
I believe there's a show going on I'm
believing he's letting this happen to
show people what what this world would
be without
actually God's letting this happen
exactly do you guys understand what's
going on Trump is the real president
under military oh so he if the President
is responsible for inflation
inflation must be Trump's fault not
bidens no Trump actually God God and
Trump are allowing Biden to pretend to
be president to show you if he were the
real president he would make inflation
go up which he did even though he's not
the real president why won't people just
accept this Luke's like all skeptical as
if this doesn't make sense he totally
has command Biden is completely
hello have you talk have you heard him
talk who votes for someone like that
this ain't real this is not a real thing
okay well
I'm just gonna make this prediction too
because I believe it Donald Trump is
going to take back over every executive
order that Biden put in will be gone
that very second he takes back over yeah
and you were saying I heard the
beginning that the military was going to
do that yes the military is going to do
it so Trump's going to do it the
military is going to do it everybody's
doing it
is that a cult member is that an
ignorant person is that a mentally ill
person I'm not sure
I'm not sure here is a woman who makes
what I call an indefeasible argument and
that's these are particular types of
arguments that make it really tough to
talk to these folks that is our right as
an American that our votes count and it
did not count on the 2020 election can I
uh press tell or ask all about that
specifically so
with all the evidence that I am you know
hearing a lot from people here that they
believe that and feel like they've seen
that evidence why for someone who's
trying to strictly go to things that
they know can be verified has that not
been shown up in any of the court cases
that have been done plus any of the
audits that have been done along the
minute there's corruption in the audits
that they weren't audits that you know
counted the votes
um I mean they were on an audit
understand what's going on these this
these are indefeasible arguments you
can't defeat them okay the example I
gave on the stream is as follows someone
comes to me with tears in their eyes and
then say David sir there's a tiger in
the room with you right now be careful
because in the studio right in the
studio with me right now there's a tiger
and I go oh okay I don't see a tiger let
me say Tiger's invisible okay invisible
tiger is unusual but fine let's do this
let's put baby powder down on the floor
so that because the invisible tiger
still has mass and volume as the tiger
moves around it will disturb the baby
powder on the floor and they'll go no
it's weightless it's a weightless
invisible tiger and then I say well at
some point this tiger is going to need
to eat let's put food down on the floor
so even if we won't see the tiger
because it's invisible and even if the
tiger also doesn't have any weight or
mass so it won't move around the baby
powder that's when it eats we'll see the
food being eaten I go no
it's a special tiger that doesn't need
to eat that's what these women are doing
they will always say no no but the
audits weren't done correctly and the
judges were corrupt
um
I mean it was an audit in a sense but it
wasn't an audit to actually right you
know it wasn't an audit that was going
to put Trump in the White House is what
she means the votes and the errors that
that went on during you know the
election I mean all Below in the world
the reason why I have a hard time
believing some of these claims is
because like the corrupt point
would maybe make more sense if a lot of
the judges that these cases were put in
front of uh were appointed by Trump and
so I guess is it even them too yeah what
you're saying yes
um well a lot of people that were
appointed by Trump
um really I mean backstabbed them yeah
exactly so it doesn't matter they became
corrupt after Trump selected them here's
a guy who just straight up doesn't
believe the election results and we're
seeing
um kind of a phenomenon going into this
midterms is very different than others
where a number of GOP candidates have
indicated kind of you've probably seen
the gas like are you gonna concede if
you lose and it's like no if we lose
it's probably because the Democrats
stole it is that a mindset that you guys
share
you want to answer anything budget oh I
definitely think it was stolen I always
think that they could tell I always
think that you have to lie and I'll
never believe that it was legit
interesting that is something that a lot
of times I'll say in conversations like
what would I have to show you or pose to
you that would change your mind on that
particular issue
I don't think there
there I remember looking back when they
was showing all these people at the
election places where the uh Boats were
and everybody's running around covering
up Windows and stuff nobody wanted them
to see him I mean who even knows what
she's talking about people covered
windows so therefore Trump actually won
then he interviews a guy who seems dead
set on repeating multiple times that he
does martial arts martial arts clearly
very important to this guy who also by
the way is wearing an ultra Maga shirt
this is Richard
mix
man
big in the news right now about the
investigation going on into him based on
the documents he had in my life it's
nonsense I think the justice department
right now is is totally uh corrupt at
the top I actually know some I train and
mixed martial arts uh we know Judo and
getting close in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu I
know a lot of people in law enforcement
I don't think the middle level people in
the FBI are crook crooked but the upper
level we've never had anybody weaponize
the Justice departments against their
opponents like Joe Biden's doing right
so what's interesting about this one is
that this is verbatim stuff that Trump
says verbatim they've weaponized the
justice department it's never been done
etc etc not particularly interesting
other than that but understand the cult
followers are paying very close
attention they're getting the exact
terminology from Trump here's another
guy who you know again I don't really
know what he's talking about totally
incoherent
well were any of us were born or our
parents or ancestors were born or was it
the Native Americans in the beginning or
the white people the original occupants
the reason you hear Trump speaking in
the background by the way is half the
crowd was leaving while Trump was
speaking so there were plenty of people
to talk to while the rally was going on
they got pushed out
I love hip-hop cultural hip-hop is like
embredded into me embred it I like that
that's a nice portmanteau of uh embedded
and bred into me it's been embredded
into Me Maybe the guy's just hungry
maybe a black soul a white body not sure
but I still have my soul and like the
soul of America is like slowly
dissipating yep so he had opinions about
things here's a guy who uh believes that
the Vatican is actually controlling
everything this one's really weird what
do you want to hear from Donald Trump
tonight
make America great again and what has
made it not great what has made an
upgrade is what's going on right now
open borders High inflation uh
everything that's going on right now
just diametically opposed the economy to
tax diametically opposed again they just
make up words they're totally confident
make them up totally confident make it's
diametically 86
000 IRS agents I mean we have all night
I mean the moon will set tomorrow by the
time so like you said there's so many
issues less zero in on one uh inflation
are you saying you blame Joe Biden for
inflation well when you sit there and
you stop fossil fuels and the country's
running out of diesel in 17 days and no
trucks no boats no play nothing's going
to be moving yeah you might want to open
up fossil fuels I think this is coming
I think it's coming from the Vatican the
vatican's meeting he hesitates before
dropping this bomb they were world
leaders and at Mount Sinai Joe Biden is
getting his March in orders from the
Jesuit oath if you open up to Jesuit and
this might be look crazy to these people
I don't really care Google to Jesuit
oath that when when Joe Biden was
elected president he opened up on a with
a Jesuit priest on a Jesuit Bible we've
had two Roman Catholic presidents this
country and Joe Biden has taken orders
just read the Jesuit Oaks that explains
so much about yeah so that's that's
pretty Bonkers stuff here's one guy who
just was Furious and started swearing
wearing an a huge huge hat
uh tell me about what you saw what you
liked I liked everything everything yep
and I want to say for what I can say it
but
even the way because you're scumbags
a change
why is she that in your mind
all right anyway I won't stick with it
the guy's just swearing so much we have
to keep bleeping and then here's the
last guy this is then we got to the Q
Anon guy uh I'm pretty far down a rabbit
hole so I don't know what I think right
now so it wasn't that me describe that
for me oh it's just the whole everything
that's going on in the world and it's
been going on in the world and I mean
it's a lot of just we'll call conspiracy
theories you know just for that heck of
it for the game what would you say your
most wild conspiracy theory would be and
and Luke's instincts impeccable there to
go right in for the most Bonkers thing
um
I guess there's really not a wildest one
I mean they're all conspiracy theories
until they are one proven true or the
masses believe them so I mean there's
there's been some wild ones over there
over the time you know with all the
child sex trafficking and Donald Trump
being the first president to fight
against that it's not a conspiracy
theory it's the truth so child sex
trafficking huge problem totally agree
with you that should be addressed it's
the connection I guess to like it's
Democratic party who's doing this and
Biden's in the back room it's good
versus evil it's it's not Republican
versus Democrat there are a lot of evil
people in the world period whether
they're Democrat or they're Republican
rhinos and they're bad for the party bad
for the country and does Trump's uh
relationship with I've seen before he
died bother you at all I don't think so
that's that's good huh there's
pedophiles everywhere it's Republicans
it's Democrats it's all of them we got
to root them out oh yeah Trump was
friends with Epstein is that a problem
no no no no and watch what the guy says
he comes up with Trump was probably
Undercover
I don't think so imagine it doesn't
bother me because I if anything I would
think that would be like a us you know
uh an inside you know I mean like he was
on the inside getting Intel there you go
same thing he did with the uh the mafia
people that saved his hotels and they
were getting information back years ago
in Trump Hotel stop playing I've seen I
think so yes interesting this gets even
crazier and we'll have the full clip
online but that one was really wild so
really really good job by Luke Beasley
you can find his YouTube channel make
sure to subscribe go to davidpackman.com
Luke and you will find it all check out
our sponsor Shaker and Spoon the monthly
cocktail subscription box that delivers
the craft cocktail experience to your
door each monthly box comes with three
original recipes created by world-class
bartenders with ingredients for 12
cocktails my favorite is the blood and
Sage it's part of the Vodka based drinks
it uses herbed Sage syrup and blood
orange Meyer lemon ginger ale delicious
refreshing I love how Shaker and Spoon
includes everything you need the
ingredients the instructions right in
the Box the recipe is easy to follow the
blood and Sage made for a very relaxing
fall afternoon on the back deck a lot of
fun with Shaker and Spoon you don't need
to seek out hard to find cocktail
ingredients or buy full-size containers
of things you'll use once this is way
more convenient Shaker and Spoon
introduces you to spirits and flavor
combinations you may never have
otherwise discovered and it it is a
fantastic holiday gift give the gift of
an awesome experience Shaker and Spoon
giving you twenty dollars off your first
box go to shakerandspoon.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is down
below